Come and write it down
Try to write it down because the number is a bit long
Just like your salary?
Yeah, it’s like this, isn’t it?
So I want to tell you something interesting about this number, I will tell you why this is interesting
This number is exactly the 13*53 quadratic
*3853
*96179. The interesting thing now is that the numbers I wrote are all prime numbers.
The number of these factorizations, 13 is a prime number, 53 is a prime number,
3853 is a prime number and 96179 is a prime number.
So these are the factorization of this number, but see how you got this number
This is the 13 you got, right?
Then 53
Then is 2
Then there is 3853, and there is 96179
What did we do? I did not do this. This is a guy named James Davis.
He is not a mathematician. According to our understanding, we really don't know who he is.
He came up with a counterexample
One of the questions about John Conway's 1000$
John Conway, famous mathematician, you should know him, very important
He came up with five questions, if anyone can solve them, or you know, find counterexamples, things like that,
Then he will give them $1,000.
Therefore, we have to have the habit of asking questions in mathematics.
You should not hope that this problem can be solved in your life.
So I think he owes this James Davis 1,000 pieces?
So what's wrong with John Conway?
Well, this is a counterexample obtained by climbing the prime number method (any number is applicable)
So if I just take a number, for example 60
Then what I have to do is write down the factorization of this number.
So in the case of 60, this is 2 squares
*3*5
Now what I have to do is (this is what John Conway suggested) to do it over and over again.
All these numbers, write them down
So I have to write 2235
So, the number I am getting now is 2235
Now, I am doing factorization again, so this happens to be
3*5
*149
So now you can do this again, create a new number,
Of course the new number will be 35149
This is a prime number
John Conway’s guess is that if you keep doing it all the time
Will break in a prime number
So give you an example.
With 25, this is of course 5 to the 2nd power, 5 to the 2nd power to take 2 to get 52
Ok, 52 is
2 to the power of 2
*13
Take 2 of the 2nd power,
So this has to be 2213, this is the prime number.
This seems to be feasible, because the two examples are feasible, and this is almost impossible to prove (this rule is correct), right?
However, no, there are many such examples.
This rule has not been found to be a counterexample
Take 20 as an example. Someone has repeated this rule hundreds of times.
Did not climb to the prime number (end point), 20 is a special (interesting) number
But in any case, there are no known counterexamples.
Until a few days ago, this blog called James Davis responded,
A math blog called Hans Havermann discusses this on the web (James Davis's reply: HEY Hans! You are the only one I found on Google to solve this problem, and I found a number that you might be interested in)
So (Hans) this post was probably released 7 to 8 months ago.
Then one day, James Davis released "I have a solution"
Then here is his solution
Then he realized that if you enter a circle, you will end up with the same number
This is a counterexample because this rule should end with a prime number
But if you fall into a loop, you will never end in a prime number
So this is one of the numbers that can cause a loop
If you fall into a loop, you use a number to do factorization
Then you do it the way we just described, you will end up with the same number
So this is an easy-to-understand counterexample.
So this is how he (James Davis) won him (John Conway), he (John Conway) 1000 yuan.
And I think this is good
You know, in this age, people can be unprofessional mathematicians, physicists, and so on.
They can still think of things that can affect the world. This is a good example.
I don't know, I don't like to think about the upcoming death (John Conway in 2017 is 80 years old)
And you know, I don't have much time. I don't quite know how much.
But I still like to do math, so I will always do it.